i should ask you something mike because
i think in conan's first week he had a
lot of bits that you had taped right
right
and he did a bit which was hilarious
okay fantastic bit where he disguised
himself as a person doing a doing a uh
market research oh yeah right that's a
great one and the market research was
with older viewers yes and they showed
tapes of conan from his old show
and asked these older viewers who hadn't
weren't regular viewers of conan right
what they thought of conan and you got
responses like i think that guy is
mentally ill
that's great and he was in disguise in
the room he's in disguise totally
disguised
and you know what mike it it killed i
thought it killed i thought it was funny
well i don't know
he's like yeah he's like he would be
like someone would say you were saying
he's like thank you
you know i'm not supposed to give my own
opinion but i have to agree this guy
that there's something wrong with this
guy yeah it was it was hilarious but
mike i'm sitting watching it thinking to
myself this isn't far off
from what's happening
you know right because it's too real
some viewers they wish weren't going to
get conan conan right it is it's
different that that's why he's good but
you know people are going to say i'm
used to that you know right 20 joke yeah
monologue and then a very formal comedy
bit at the desk right
that's what i like you know and then you
bring on
you know
don rickles
you know that that's what you do and
instead conan has younger
hotter acts and will ferrell and people
like this right and they're doing wacky
stuff and they're doing crazy stuff
right and it's like that audience
research group who are like ah
he makes me uncomfortable
right so it's so in the back of my head
and of course i'm thinking book wise at
the time yeah i think book wise i hope
this isn't
also an omen for for conan that he's
done a bit that shows what nbc is
complaining about interesting
well that i mean to us we were just like
this is hilarious
no doubt
so no doubt you know i
we just thought
it's as long as we were being funny of
course that would win out in the end so
i'm not saying it did something wrong i
just yeah
it just resonated with me that that was
sort of what was right what was going on
and of course it played into conan's
self-deprecation yeah yes yeah yeah yeah
look at this guy he's he's awful he's
crazy look at that red hair
right i mean you know he
and and that's
that was great as a viewer who likes
conan i loved it
as an executive yeah because they
probably were running focus groups and
maybe these are leno's viewers those
people were leno's viewers that's what i
thought